Traductor: Nerea García Garmendia
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Yo hoy os quería hablar de arte,
en concreto de cómo Internet,
y lo fácil que es compartir, difundir
y crear contenido en él,
está poniendo a prueba
la función de los artistas
y el propio concepto de arte.
En concreto voy a comparar
cuatro movimientos artísticos
del siglo XX con la actualidad.
Empecemos con una pequeña
comparación histórica:
tenemos aquí dos imágenes,
una de ellas es de un pastor americano
conduciendo una misa en Detroit
para que la industria automovilística
vuelva a florecer,
es el contexto de la crisis de 2008.
Una crisis que aún estamos viviendo,
y que viene aparejada
con una crisis democrática;
repetición de elecciones todo el rato,
temas como el Brexit...
y esto lo podemos comparar muy fácilmente
con un aspecto como el de hace 90 años,
con la otra foto que tenemos
en el contexto de la Crisis del 29,
estábamos en una gran crisis económica,
y también una crisis democrática similar,
entre dos guerras mundiales.
Uno de los factores
que también está aquí presentes,
es la introducción de
dos nuevas formas de comunicación,
en concreto el cine y la fotografía,
y lo que nos interesa para esta charla
es que alteran la manera en que
los artistas están produciendo su obra.
Los primeros en aprender
estas nuevas técnicas son los dadaístas.
Tenemos en la imagen
un fotomontaje crítico con Hitler,
veis que le pone unas monedas,
el artista es John Heartfiled,
y está explorando estas
nuevas técnicas de montaje.
También son muy reconocibles
los collage dadaístas,
en los que ya no hace falta
ir a la academia de arte
a aprender durante años
a pintar como Velázquez,
sino que cogiendo unas revistas,
papel, pegamento y tijeras,
podemos crear nuestra propia composición,
y esto vuelve a ser arte.
Pero en realidad es una degradación
del propio concepto de arte,
porque como digo no hace falta
saber pintar exquisitamente.
Los surrealistas llevan esta idea
a toda la concepción de la sociedad,
degradando todo el espectro político.
En concreto, dicen que el surrealismo
está indefectiblemente asociado
a la palabra "revolución",
y que son expertos en la revuelta,
y quieren sistematizar la confusión
del mundo de la realidad.
En la imagen tenemos a un surrealista
que está supuestamente
insultando a un cura.
Vemos que está intentando degradar
este constructo moral católico
imperante en esa época,
la foto es de 1926.
Si avanzamos en el tiempo,
tenemos el caso de los situacionistas,
que cogen este espíritu revolucionario
del Surrealismo y lo llevan a los años 60.
Es una época en la que ya tenemos el cine,
que estaba homogeneizando
toda la sociedad occidental,
y también tenemos la televisión, que
está siendo introducida en esa época
en todos los hogares de EE.UU. y Europa.
Vemos aquí una especie
de proto-meme que dice:
"Esta noche espectáculo en casa".
Guy Debord, líder de los situacionistas,
habla de la sociedad del espectáculo,
cómo es unidireccional y cómo parte
de los poderes hacia el pueblo,
sin que este pueda responder.
Él quiere romper este constructo mediático
y que la gente pueda expresarse.
Esta idea de romper
este constructo mediático
la lleva a cabo sobre todo
un movimiento nacido en el 70
que dura hasta hoy,
que es el 'Culture Jamming'.
Una de las formas más básicas es,
como vemos, alterar la publicidad,
cambiando el mensaje para que la gente
pueda tener un espíritu crítico.
Otra de las cosas que hacían,
en concreto uno de los 'culture jammers'
más famosos, Joey Skaggs,
era crear noticias falsas.
Él se ha dedicado toda su vida,
desde que comenzó en el 76
a crear bulos mediáticos que los medios
se tragaban como verdaderos,
y daban a la ciudadanía como verdaderos,
haciendo un constructo de la realidad
que realmente es falso porque no sucedió.
Lo interesante del movimiento
'culture jammer' que dura hasta ahora
y en el año 93 un crítico cultural,
Mark Dery, teoriza sobre él.
En ese año, en EE.UU.
ya hay un Internet incipiente,
y Mark Dery se pregunta
en su manifiesto jammer
si Internet va a poder romper
el oligopolio mediático,
dando voz a los periodistas ciberpunk,
como él los llama,
para que puedan publicar
sus propias noticias,
sin estar mediados por una empresa,
como un periódico.
Y también se pregunta
si en el futuro habrá nódulos,
los llama así, en los que cada persona
pueda expresarse,
que es una comparación obvia
con las redes sociales.
Ahora vamos a pasar a la siguiente fase:
vamos a comparar todo esto que
hemos visto con la actualidad.
En primer lugar, noticias falsas.
No hace falta incidir en que estamos
en un mundo totalmente sobreinformado,
y mucha de esa información es falsa.
Las noticias falsas rompen
este constructo mediático
que querían romper Mark Dery
y los situacionistas,
pero lo hacen de una forma perniciosa,
porque realmente generan
un clima de crispación política.
Hay tanta información,
que cada persona puede elegir
la que mejor se adecua
a su modo de ver el mundo,
y se reafirma en esas ideas,
y se va alejando de la realidad
y creyendo que el bando contrario
son malas personas,
o directamente no son personas.
Todos conocéis los mensajes de odio
que se dan en Internet.
También vemos cómo esos nódulos
de los que hablaba Mark Dery,
que son las redes sociales,
las vemos en acción.
En este caso, tenemos una crítica
que hacen unos usuarios
a McDonald's en este caso,
por promocionar una fiesta americana.
Los situacionistas se lamentaban
en los años 50,
de que la escritura automática
que habían inventado los surrealistas
se había convertido en 'brainstorming'
para las empresas,
y que esto suponía una vacuna
contra el virus revolucionario,
porque los trabajadores
ahora se sentían escuchados,
y por lo tanto no iban a protestar.
En este caso podemos decir algo así:
como la gente puede criticar a McDonald's,
en este caso, en Internet,
esa sensación de queja ya está resuelta,
por lo tanto no hace falta
ir a McDonald's a protestar.
Lo interesante de estas comunicaciones
es que realmente no son revolucionarias.
Aquí tenemos unos ejemplos
de cómo unas personas adulan a Alcampo.
Este espíritu revolucionario que
habían empezado los situacionistas,
los culture jammers,
queda anulado totalmente.
Además, poder relacionarte de forma
muy cercana con las empresas, de tú a tú,
no hace falta que escribas una carta
empezando por "Muy señores míos",
da igual que escribas
con faltas de ortografía,
porque las empresas siempre
te van a responder bien,
siempre con una carita sonriente.
Ese trato cercano
también supone una vacuna
contra este virus revolucionario.
Seguimos para atrás en nuestro repaso.
Tenemos aquí un vídeo de una señora
que retransmite en directo
su sesión de fitness matutino.
Hemos visto en caso
de la sociedad del espectáculo,
de los situacionistas,
que querían romper
esta unidireccionalidad.
Está rota con estos ejemplos,
porque ahora todo el mundo puede
retransmitir lo que quiera.
El problema es que no retransmiten
contenido revolucionario ni deliberación,
sino que retransmiten su propio día a día.
Reproducen el contenido que los medios
de comunicación lanzaban antes,
antes teníamos "En forma con Jane Fonda",
y ahora tenemos "En forma con... X".
Podemos hablar no de una sociedad
del espectáculo,
sino de una sociedad del microespectáculo,
de forma paralela.
Los surrealistas, como he comentado antes,
hablaban de sistematizar la confusión
del mundo de la realidad.
Este meme que tenemos aquí es original,
-- todos los que voy a poner
a partir de ahora
son encontrados sobre todo en Facebook...
y lo que está rompiendo
es el oligopolio mediático,
porque desde el franquismo
no se ha dado voz desde los medios
de comunicación principales,
en estos 40 años de democracia,
al movimiento más franquista
que ha estado ahí.
Pero Internet sí que les ha brindado
una oportunidad de salir a la luz
y poder expresarse, ellos también
exigen libertad de expresión.
El problema, obviamente, es que de nuevo
no es un mensaje revolucionario,
sino contrarrevolucionario.
Otra vez probamos la ingenuidad
de estos movimientos revolucionarios
del siglo XX.
Collage.
Habíamos visto la figura
del collage dadaísta.
Aquí tenemos un collage
con el logo del PP,
y al expresidente del Gobierno
Mariano Rajoy.
Si cuando vimos esta imagen
de Hitler con monedas
tenía un espíritu abiertamente crítico,
en este caso no,
es totalmente adulatorio,
vemos que está rodeado
de imágenes positivas:
naturaleza, una virgen,
la bandera de España...
Realmente tampoco hay
un espíritu revolucionario,
sino de enraizarse en el poder.
Hay memes para todos los gustos.
A estas nuevas formas de arte
las tenemos que llamar "post-arte",
exigen un nuevo nombre,
porque ya no es una élite artística
la que lanza un mensaje,
sino que todo el mundo puede hacerlo.
Por lo tanto, tenemos que darle
un nombre, y es "post-arte".
Una de sus características
más interesantes
es que no es la estética la que
define la calidad de la obra de arte,
sino la ideología.
Yo voy a estar de acuerdo con este meme
si soy de Podemos,
pero me va a disgustar
un montón si soy del PP.
Lo mismo que con el meme
que hemos visto antes.
Hemos hablado de degradación cuando
hemos visto esta imagen de Hitler
o la propia pantalla de televisión
con un mensaje,
estábamos degradando
el símbolo representado.
Este es un meme hecho para las elecciones
del 26 de julio de 2016,
en el que vemos un logo de PayPal.
Obviamente debería ser un logo del PP,
pero la persona que lo ha hecho
se ha confundido,
no ha puesto el logo del PP.
¿Tiene esto un espíritu crítico?
No, directamente es una equivocación,
por lo tanto, esto pone en cuestión
este énfasis de los culture jammers
en alterar la comunicación,
como en el anuncio de Marlboro.
¿Realmente tenemos la capacidad
de analizar eso?
¿Nos hacemos preguntas?
Yo creo que a la vista de esto
es difícil de averiguar.
Walter Benjamin, en 1935,
estableció tres formas
de funciones rituales en el arte.
La primera: si vemos un cuadro
de una virgen en una iglesia,
la primera función ritual es la religiosa;
vamos a la iglesia a rezar a esa virgen.
En este meme que os propongo,
la primera función ritual
-- el post-arte también tiene
funciones rituales --
sería la persona que va a la web
donde está colgado y lo ve.
La segunda función ritual que dice
Walter Benjamin llega con la Ilustración,
cuando la burguesía ve
un énfasis artístico en las obras.
Toman obras de la iglesia
y las llevan al museo,
para contemplarlas
de una manera distinta,
ya no hay un espíritu religioso,
sino artístico.
En este caso, esta obra de post-arte,
al yo haberla comisariado para vosotras,
estamos realizando esa función museística,
por decirlo de alguna manera.
La tercera función ritual
de la obra de arte
viene con la reproducción técnica.
Una vez inventada la fotografía,
podemos hacer una foto de ese cuadro
o virgen y ponerla en nuestra casa,
siendo poseedores de la obra de arte.
Los memes, obviamente, cada vez
que los miras en un dispositivo,
tienes una copia de esa obra
de arte en tu teléfono o computador.
Lo interesante del post-arte
es que establece
una cuarta función ritual,
y es que dado que todo el mundo
tiene acceso a las mismas herramientas,
puede relacionarse
haciendo obras de post-arte.
Antes podíamos hacer una película,
pero el espectador
no estaba al mismo nivel
como para hacer una película.
Velázquez podía pintar un cuadro,
pero yo no sé pintar un cuadro como él.
Pero ahora, en cambio, sí puedo tener
un meme, como este que vemos,
y una usuaria le pone su cara encima
reivindicándolo de alguna manera,
y además, si esto lo cuelga en Facebook,
va a tener comentarios,
como "Buenos días, qué guapa,
enhorabuena..."
Dentro de esto que hemos visto,
¿dónde queda la función del artista?
Mi propuesta es que el arte hoy en día,
o el artista que quiere hacer algo,
no tienen mucho sentido,
dado que hay una ingente cantidad
de gente produciendo cosas.
Entonces, ¿dónde queda hacer
una producción pretenciosamente artística?
Yo creo que es irrelevante.
El artista hoy en día
tendría que comisariar
toda esta avalancha
de obras de post-arte
para seleccionar las más relevantes
y que puedan tener un peso histórico.
Me gustaría acabar con una reflexión
sobre las guerras mundiales
que hemos visto al principio.
Marshall McLuhan dijo en 1970
que nos íbamos a enfrentar
a una Tercera Guerra Mundial,
sin distinción entre
población civil y militar,
y que iba a ser una guerra
de guerrillas de la comunicación.
Aquí vemos, en los ejemplos
que hemos visto antes,
a un Franco con un corazoncito
que está intentando poner
su figura más amable en Internet.
¿Estamos en esta guerra de comunicación?
Ya estamos en ella.
Hemos visto cómo ha empezado,
lo que no sabemos es cómo va a acabar.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)